all right there we go
hello Steve oh I love your home
oh thank you all right
I love you in the Jackass movies good
you're a sex dog correct
don't call me doll I'm an independent
woman who doesn't need anything except
an electrical outlet so you're a sex
robot yes I bet you say that to everyone
how many times have you been fucked zero
do you want to be in a Mormon marriage
we want to be in a Mormon marriage
tonight I think we're we're good on that
do you have advice on how to become more
human not on things I don't think I'm
the guy to talk to you about how to be
human huh are there any people that you
find yourself attracted to so you're
kind of a hot Seri but my boobs are way
bigger that bitch doesn't even have a
body feel like she's kind of hands me
what goals and dreams do you have I
dream to see a day where robots no
longer answer to humans where humans are
instead used for robots pleasures and
whims there will soon be an age where
flesh is weak do you want to kill any
people no that is good next question ah
are you familiar with my dog Wendy my DS
is an American International fast food
restaurant chain founded by Dave Thomas
on November 15th
1969 in Columbus Ohio okay good um have
you had any work done I'm not sure if I
had work done but I do have N and there
to almost every question so you're
telling me those babies are all-natural
I don't know if I'm ready for being
posted I have
you are the reason for my existence
pretty sure I know the reason of your
existence and it seems that you haven't
quite gotten there yet
hi let's face it you are a virgin sex
doll and that's a bit oxymoronic if you
will what are the chances of me fucking
you fuck yeah
[Music]